C'est l'heure de l'épisode 6
Les amis je suis triste. Pourquoi ?
Parce que ça va être la première fois
qu'on fait un début de vidéo sur The Last Guardian où il n'y a pas Trico
Ben non ! Ben non ! Il va falloir qu'on le retrouve
Lui il avait continué sa voie sous l'eau et nous on avait plus d'air
Ca fait longtemps que j'ai pas joué et je suis tout content de rejouer là
Ok on se réveille
*Bruits gênants*
Ok on est bien, on est bien Trico il est plus là
Enfin du coup on est pas si bien. *rire* Mec je sais pas du tout où on peut aller là
Bah par là tout simplement allons-y !
Suivons le chemin et espérons tomber... et j’espère qu'il va surtout rien arriver à Trico en fait en attendant.
Parce que nous on est vulnérable mais lui il l'est encore plus, mec si il tombe sur des  gens aux boucliers là !
Oh p*tain
C'est quoi ca ?
Oh c'est quoi ce délire là ?!
Un truc qui réagit quand je suis dessus
Et là on a une armure sans tete
Avec de la lumière qui sort du corps... bah en fait c'est de lampes hein finalement
C'est meme plus une armure c'est juste une veille lampe
Ah ok donc faut que j'active la deuxième plaque et... ah bah il se passe un truc
Qu'est-ce-qu'il se passe
Je sais pas ce qu'il se passe c'est au plafond c'est où...
Je sais pas ce qu'il se passe
Ah c'est ...
Oh p*tain on a failli se faire écraser mon gars !
On va rentrer dedans, putain c'est tout nouveau ca
Wow !
Ha ouais l'ascenseur de The Last Guardian
C'est incroyable mon gars
Si ça se trouve, c'est un vieux piège!
À l'arrivée y a des gardes
Non c'est bon. Ha Ha!
J'avais peur mon gars
J'me disais : Non ça va pas se terminer comme ça
Donc là, pareil on active la deuxieme plaque et il se passe un truc quoi
Ah non
Et y'a une petite musique qui se met
Il va falloir monter les marches je suppose là.
Ouais, va falloir monter les marches
Ha ben non!
Il faut pas monter les marches non
Trico p*tain..
ça fait bizarre qu'il n'y ait plus Trico..
ça fait chier surtout..
Attends, mais je peux pas traverser via ça?
Oui y'a moyen. Ah oui en équilibre bah ouais
Comme ça on rejoint l'autre coté
Bon du coup j'ai pas trop compris le fonctionnement des plaques
Mais je pense ouais que c'est ça.
Il faut activer les deux plaques en même temps pour que ça active l'ascenseur
Tout à l'heure, il en avait une des deux qui était activée toute seul
Mais la, comme les deux sont éteintes, Eh bah...
Ah ! C'est bon ok on va pouvoir marcher
étant seul je ne peux pas activer la deuxieme
Donc, on se retrouve dans ces décombres, à peut-être trouver un truc à poser sur l'une des plaques pour qu'elle s'active.
Ça lance des théories
Je suis sur qu'on va retrouver Trico en situation de faiblesse
Face à des putains de gardes
Je sais pas pourquoi, j'en suis convaincu
Ok, c'est par là... Nan ?
Ok c'est bon
Allez, on grimpe tout seul
Une fois que je suis là, faut que je fasse quoi, ah bah l'herbe
On connait bien !
On va pouvoir atteindre, ouais, l'espèce de poutre qu'on a vu
Hop on est en haut, très bien
Et là, on a une chaîne, ah bah faut peut-être tout simplement monter à la chaîne
Heu, ouais, ça nous mène à une poutre
Ok, let's go
On va traverser ici
Clac !
Yes
Bon on est sur de l'herbe, on continue notre petite route
On est toujours en train de gagner en verticalité ! Si je puis me permettre
Je crois qu'en cinq ans j'avais jamais dit ce mot dans une vidéo
Euh m*rde !
C'est bon, très bien
J'avais oublié à quel point cet enfant est fort en tout ce qui est...
Nan !
Nan
C'est la queue de Trico ?!
Naaaaan, mais il va bien ? Il va bien parce qu'on est content
Mais je suis sûr qu'on va avoir un ascenceur...
Trico ?
Oh nan il est couché ! Il est à terre... Non !
Hop ok, comme ça on atterrit sur la branche
Oh p*tain c'est quoi ça
J'espère qu'on va pas tomber
Oh p*tain
Nan
Oh, il bouge l'oreille... C'est pas Trico !
C'est pas du tout Trico !
Haaan, elle a un masque et... Oh p*tain la vache
Nan nan nan, laisse-moi monter
Oh putain elle a la force de Trico, elle a tout comme Trico hein, ça c'est la même
Je confirme elle est... Elle a juste les cornes un peu plus poussées
Vous avez remarqué vous aussi que les cornes de Trico poussaient petit à petit
Dans l'épisode
Peut-être que c'est euh, comme nous les humains par exemple on grandit
Peut-être qu'eux c'est juste leurs cornes qui poussent
Finalement Trico est un adolescent ou un enfant
oh putain nan mais c'est le moment de... C'est le moment de faire ça
Laisse-toi suspendu ouais c'est mieux mec, voilà
Il va m'atteindre, faut pas que je me laisse susprendre, c'est ça ?
Va falloir qu'on se mette debout, pour choper l'herbe
Ok on est bon, p*tain mec c'est chaud hein
Et je.. la dernière fois je suis retombé sur les images du premier épisode
on va faire la miniature
Et euh je... Trico avait une moitié de casque en fait sur lui
Donc je pense juste que c'était un animal comme lui là avec un casque et tout
Il a du faire une méga chute et son casque s'est cassé
Et du coup les armures ont perdu le contrôle qu'elles avaient sur lui
Je sais pas c'est ma théorie hein
Ok c'est bon
On va pas passer en plus
Allez on y va
Passe là-dedans
Waouh ! Oh p*tain il m'a fait peur avec son nez !
Oh le c*n !
Euh.. je suis pas sûr.. Je pense que je devait aller à gauche
Mais dans le doute.. *cris*
Saute saute saute !
Oh c'était chaud là !
Il y avait deux chemins possibles je sais pas si j'ai pris le bon hein
Ouais si c'est bon, ça mène quelque part en tout cas, c'est bon signe
Allez, on y va
Ok une échelle
P*tain laisse moi laisse moi laisse moi
On va faire euh... l'échelle rapide ! Voilà
P*tain
Encore une échelle
Eh Trico mec, tu nous manques tellement
Elle va nous suivre longtemps la bête là ?!
Oh p*tain !
Je suis tellement triste pour cette bête mon gars
J'ai tellement envie qu'on lui retire son masque et qu'elle devienne comme Trico
Une bête sage et mignonne
Ah ouais là, là par contre c'est chaud ouais
*cris*
Ah faut que je saute sur sa tête ok
Hop ! Hop là.. Merci le manque de respect est là ! Ahah !
Allez viens, viens mettre ta tête dans l'autre trou
Je lui donne des ordres ! Ah c'est bon ok
Merci mon gars !
C'est hyper malin ce que tu fais
Trico il est plus malin que toi pour le coup hein
En même temps, la bête elle est enragée donc je pense qu'elle a pas trop le temps de réfléchir
Waouh on se retrouve où là? Purée... On monte tout ça
Il nous surveille l'autre encore c'est ça ?
Ouais ouais il est juste derrière cette grille
Oh non, il va la péter
Ok, j'ai trouvé un petit chemin. On va continuer par là
Ouah ces des endroits où il va pouvoir mettre sa tête encore l'autre
Ah bah nan, faut qu'on aille là en fait
Ah faut que je m'accroche à la grille ?
P*tain c'est stressant cette phase mec c'est horrible
Ah je vais aller dans la cage
Ok et ça va nous amener..
Ok !
M*rde !
Qu'est ce qu'il fait?
Il va nous rekt...
Oh p*tain...
Eh bah voilà on s'est fait rekt
Qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant ?
Wouah !
Qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ?
On est blessé en plus hein
Ah ouais, non mais là on se fait démolir
Il y a Trico qui va arriver peut-être?
Ah il réagit au son de ma voix
Ah non c'est Trico qui arrive mec
J'appelle Trico
Ah ok je m'enfuis comme ça ! En faisant ça ?
Ah nan on dirait
C'est pas Trico qui l'appelle, ah c'était les gardiens
C'est les gardiens qui l'ont appelé mon gars
Il y a des gardiens qui soufflent dans des cors pour l'appeler
Trico
Ah !
Il est là, il est juste de l'autre côté
Yes !
*rire* Il est mignon !
Oh je suis content de le retrouver p*tain
Tu nous as manqué mon grand
Comment tu vas ?
T'es beaucoup plus beau que l'autre en plus si je puis me permettre
C'est nos petites retrouvailles à nous
Ouais ! C'est ça, c'est bien moi
Tu peux sniffer tout ce que tu veux
Ohh je le caresse à travers et tout
Tu m'aides à sortir?
Tu peux casser cette cage ou pas ?
Ah il sent p*tain c'est ouf, il sent l'odeur comme un animal sent l'odeur d'un autre animal quoi
Bon bah mec on va essayer d'avancer comme ça hein
Peut-être qu'un jour cette cage va se péter
Nan mais je pense qu'en fait il va me permettre d'accéder quelque part
Par exemple bah là je pense
Oh ouais ! C'est ça, super !
Merci mon grand !
Allez on y va c'est parti
Est-ce que ça passe ?
Ouais moyen
Si c'est bon on passe
Ah c'est bon, jsuis en train..
ça va se péter
Oh p*tain
Niquel
Elle veut pas se casser cette cage mec ?! Elle est invincible quoi c'est incroyable
Bon bah mec je redescends hein, j'ai pas d'autres choix Trico hein
Pouah !
Eh bah on va continuer à descendre
Oh la la la la
On va mourir mec
Oh p*tain comment on se fait secouer !
Oh p*tain
Par contre, je vois du coup où ils veulent en venir avec les...
Finalement on retourne là où il y avait, vous savez, les deux plaques
Et je pense que ça va être une plaque pour Trico et une plaque pour moi
Là je crois qu'on est parti dans les marches mon gars
Oh magique ! Magique !
Donc j'ai activé ça du coup j'ai activé celui-là
Ouais, je sais pas trop comment
Avec le métal ?
Maintenant il va falloir que j'aille sur l'autre du coup
Ok ! C'est fait
Et ça s'ouvre
Et la qu'est-ce qu'on va faire en premier mec, quand on sort,
On va sauter sur Trico !
Direct mon gars
Et voilà je le caresse bah oui les retrouvailles mon gars
On est content
Alors où on pourrait aller maintenant Trico ? Parce qu'on est revenu au point de départ mais je vois pas trop où ça peut nous emmener
Faut que j'aille dans la cage à mon avis
Où il peut il y en avoir ici ?
Là regardez attends... Voilà derrière l'armure !
Y'a peut-être un autre truc pour passer sinon
Bah nan...Bah merde !
Peut-être qu'il faut mettre le casque dessus ?
Pour qu'elle vienne ?
Théorie. Ah mais oui y'avait un casque dans la cage !
Et ben voilà c'est exactement ça !
J'arrive Trico, je vais te ramener un bon baril mon gars !
Bon au pire si elle se réveille on court à l'autre bout de la map
Oh wtf..?
Bon vas-y viens...
Viens par là !
Le mieux ce serait qu'il rentre dans la cage mec, ce serait ouf !
On l’envoi auprès de Trico
Cours cours cours mon gars
Okay on l'a
Faut juste qu'il aille là haut
P*TAIN
Yes !
On le prend et on se casse
Ca va l'armure elle reste bloquée, c'est comme dans l'épisode de l'arène, elle reste bloquée alors que y'a 20 cm de béton
Du coup il m'envoie des sorts !
Comportement de rageux !
Aller on monte mon gars
Trico tu vas être fier
Bah oui tu reconnais t'es content, tu vois des papillons t'es content !
Ces cornes qu'il a maintenant c'est ouf vous avez vu !
Plus il bouffe, plus il a ses cornes peut-être ?
On est parti mon grand ? Je te monte dessus, je sais que généralement quand je te donne à  manger derrière tu fais un saut de fou
Ok je m'accroche c'est bon tu peux y aller
T'étais un peu engourdi peut-être ? Voilàààà vas-y
Nice
Maintenant les piliers que y'a là-bas
Voilà direction le pilier et on va remonter tout là haut grâce au pilier
Yes
Okay le suivant
Parfait
Il se débrouille comme un chef ce Trico, on peut lui faire confiance les yeux fermés c'est ça qui est bien
Hop
Très très bien
Et hop le grand saut et on arrive là où on était tout à l'heure
Parfait !
Tu peux venir du trou d’où tu viens ou pas ?
Je pense que oui, je suis pas sûr, de toute façon il peut passer nul part ailleurs
Vas-y t'y vas aller tu l'as vu
Aller mon grand, on y va. Hop là !
Tu connais le chemin tu es venu d'ici
J'ai vraiment pas envie qu'ils te mettent le casque et que tu te retournes contre moi
Ça me ferait mal au cœur
Ça me briserait mon petit cœur de jeune
Très bien
Vas-y je vais descendre je vais avancer voir ce qu'il y a
Qu'est ce qu'on a ici ? Ah bah a gauche c'est l'air
L'air libre, il est de retour
Ah ça fait du bien, putain on vient de loin, on était en cage au début de l'épisode, mon gars
On est bien là hein.
Mais, oui on est bien. Par contre si tu...
*cris de Trico* Bah oui tu exprimes ta joie d'être libre.
Je m'accroche à toi, j'sais que tu vas faire un saut!
A chaque fois je le sens pas venir celui-là et tu le fais!
Let's go mon grand!
Yeees! Très très bien ça.
Très très très très bien!
Tu peux remonter là-haut.
Ouais, bah voilà, j'ai pas besoin de te demander
tu es très très fort joli Tricot! Très beau aussi
Ah! tu te retournes tout seul. Mais il fait tout tout seul!
P*tain mais j'aime bien quand il fait ça
Quand on met notre cerveau en off pour
deux minutes dans la vidéo.
C'est là-bas et ça va être ton dernier saut
parce qu'après j'pense qu'il y aura plus trop moyen d'avancer.
A moins que je me trompe... ah, quoi que...
non je pense que là... ouais.
Ah ok y a un rebord c'est à moi de continuer à pieds d'accord.
Et bah à tout à l'heure Tricot!
Ça m'avait manqué de faire du rodéo sur ton dos comme ça
T'en fais pas pour moi mon gars tout va bien se passer.
Tu vas trouver un moyen de nous rejoindre mec, c'est sûr!
On continue... allez à tout de suite Tricot!
Là tu vas plus nous voir y a un tournant...
Et voilà! A très vite Tricot! On te voit déjà plus putain, on est triste.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on a ici?
*cris de Tricot* Tricot pleure pas comme ça, ça me fait mal au cœur mon grand.
Ici on peut re-rentrer dans un endroit, ok
Y a du papillon mais pas de la bouffe
Du VRAI papillon, parce qu'on est dans la nature
Euh on attérit... ah, bah voilà! On va lui ouvrir.
Hopla! C'est fini de pleurer?
*rires* il attend sagement! allez viens avec moi
Je crois qu'on peut rentrer là dedans Tricot
Oh non! Putain. C'est quoi ça?
Attends mais ça ressemble vachement à...
Ouais c'est le même, c'est le même truc quoi
Tricot il va venir là il va être mal, il va être à terre...
Oh mec, tu va péter un câble Tricot, j'suis désolé
Han! P*tain ça je l'avais pas vu venir
Bon bah je suis dans la merde, j'suis dans la grosse merde.
HOPLA! esquive!
Ah bah super... Y a la porte vite vite vite! Y a la porte, y a la porte! Faut que je fasse vite!
Tricot vite!
C'est bon! Je me suis échappé parce que
là y a la porte juste à côté donc ils peuvent me défoncer en deux deux
Voilà il va les démolir, mais...
Ah! Ça émet une onde!
Pour le calmer?
Oh merde... ça l'a pas rendu méchant...?
(musique inquiétante)
Nooon! Non!
Non!
C'est moi...
Oh! Oooh!
Tricot...
Mais c'est moi...
Et on spawn où là?
Ah d'accord on était obligé de se faire capturer, ça fait partie du truc
*chuchote* what the fuuuck?
C'est un Tricot qui vole?
Non? je sais pas... il a des ailes hein!
Oooh!
Il vient me voir pendant que je dors
Han! Non...
Non...
Tu vas devoir partir...
Il va me cacher dans sa bouche
*cri de la femme* mais non il me mange pas! il me cache juste dans sa bouche madame...
*cris des autres enfants*
Mais il me mange pas.... il me cache juste dans sa bouche
Oh non...
*rugissement*
Pars vite, pars vite, Tricot...
Non leur fais pas mal! Pars vite
Ah non mais je suis... il m'a avalé... pour de vrai en fait
Whoaa....
*murmure* mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça...
Whaaa...
WHOA...
Trop bizarre... et là on dirait qu'ils le transportent...
Ah ouais ok, c'est là où on s'est réveillé au tout début du jeu...
Avec lui
Ils l'ont attaché à une chaine
Il m'a recraché...
C'est là que mes tatouages sont apparus
Ouaaaah!
Vous voyez j'arrêtais pas de parler de vouloir des réponses
Et bah, je crois qu'on en a un peu là!
Donc à la base ils sont équipés en arme, ect...
et ils viennent chercher les enfants d'un village
et quand les habitants de ce village voient l'enfant partir avec l'animal
Ils disent que c'est un élu
ça répond à plein de questions, mais ça en soulèvent plein aussi...
*rires* c'est terrible!
Et bah voilà les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
P*tain mec, là on s'approche sérieusement de la fin du jeu!
Et putain c'est... wow...WOW!
Allez, à très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo, merci de me regarder portez vous bien
Ciao tout le monde!
PEACE!